let's go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 a lot of people calling in with
a lot of different things they want to
talk about let's go next to the 5 1 6
area code caller from five one six who's
this where are you calling from hi David
my name is Paul calling from Los Angeles
go ahead Paul I did have a long-winded
question but stick with me so you don't
mind I'll probably get into some hot
water
do you field recent scandals affecting
the women's March regarding Sarsour
Malorie demonstrating their refusal to
condemn Farrakhan and their claims their
purported claims of that that Jews were
uphold white supremacy and art were
responsible for the African slave trade
and even their wrong omission of Jewish
women and leadership roles and omitting
Jews from its list of so called unity
principles which were minority groups
whose rights you were making it their
mission making it in their mission
project as well as Rashida slaves dual
loyalty charts on Twitter while
supporting while supporting a
Palestinian Shah and putting a map of
the Middle East in her office upon
getting sworn in and Ilhan Omar's
blatant baton switch regarding their
stance her stance on BDS and that she
well when she was speaking about it
during before the election in synagogues
at just the court Jewish votes and then
immediately reversed her stance upon
upon her election do you think that
these are clear examples of
anti-semitism marketing itself as
anti-zionism and an even show very eerie
similarities to what's going on in the
labor movement in in Britain at this
time okay there's about 10 different
things in there and they're not all
exactly related in the way that you're
sort of packaging them so let's see if
we can take them one one at a time as
far as the women's March leaders I've
been criticizing them for two years at
this point
and I you know I take some
heat for it but I call it like I see it
I say whatever I want on the show if
people disagree with me that that's
totally fine if they don't want to
support my show because of my view on
the women's March okay but I think that
it's become toxic I think it's it's
basically self imploded we played clips
from the Tameka Mallory bobland
interview on the on the view earlier
this week it's just a total
embarrassment and I think that there are
a number of different criticisms to make
there as far as Rashida you Leoben Ilan
Omar and their positions on on BDS and
the israeli-palestinian conflict I'm
really only familiar with Rasheeda Talib
and how she at one point claimed to be
for a two-state solution but now I guess
is for a one-state solution so I
disagree with that position I don't know
if it's bait and switch or not that
requires a little bit of a subjective
analysis I'm just not familiar enough
with Ilan omar's possess I highly
suggest you I highly suggest that you
take a read at the statement that was
released regarding the BDS stance I
don't remember if it was too late for
Omar but I think it was on Mars prior to
the election it was very much showing
you know her support for a dialogue and
agency on both sides and so forth is
very antithetical to a one-state
solution with feet so anyway yeah no
that's what I'm saying I that that I'm
so I'm against that I'm for a two-state
solution to your more general question
about anti-zionism being used as a veil
for anti-semitism I've spoken about this
many many times I'm not in a position to
say if any of the individuals you listed
are anti-semitic deep down I just don't
know anti-semitism masquerading as
anti-zionism exists not all anti-zionism
is anti-semitism it's very important to
be clear of that I also am skeptical of
people who even use the term
anti-zionism because they're using a
perverted definition of Zionism because
me you know I as someone who's
from Argentina a family went to
Argentina from Eastern Europe for a
number of different humanitarian reasons
both before and during World War two
Zionism in in that era really just meant
we think there should be a place where
we know Jews won't get kicked out
now Zionism is used as a catch-all for
support of outrageous Benjamin Netanyahu
policies and settlements and all of that
stuff which is not ever really what
Zionism was so there's also like a
semantic argument to be had there but
you know I think that you're bringing up
all good issues but I don't see them as
one that require one answer these are
all like five or six separate things I
disagree I mean I agree with your your
analysis on the perversion of Zionism
but I disagree but I thank you so much
for commenting okay but can I fight so
when you say you disagree are you saying
that a critique of Tameka Mallory and
Linda Sarsour is the exact same critique
and analysis as to the question of
rashida to leaves position on the
israeli-palestinian conflict I mean they
they're literally two different things
that I think would require three
analyses of course but I do think that
there is a broader a pretty clear
broader sort of agenda here which is
using platforms and leftist grievances
to further a pro-palestinian slash
anti-israel agenda and that certainly
exists I would want to be really sure of
where it where I'm claiming it exists
before I say that because that's just
not always the case but you're bringing
up good balance and I really appreciate
the phone call Paul hope to hear from
you again